على تخومي مدينه تعز كان سكانها يعملون ان
ينجح اتفاق الهدنه في كسر حصار مليشيات
الحوثي وفتح طريق يعود ربط المدينه بسائر
محافظه اليمن لكن الحصار الخارقه على
المدينه حرك عجله البناء وعجل العمل على
انشاء مطار المخاب تمويل من دوله الامارات
العربيه المتحده وباشراف عضو مجلس القياده
الرئاسي طارق محمد عبد الله صالح فالعمل
هنا يجري على قدم وساق لاستكمال المرحله
الاخيره من هذا المطار ليصبح منفدا جويا
لتعز بديلا لمطار القديم الخاضع لسيطره
الميليشيات الحوثيه همم
المعايير التي تتبناها منظمه الايكاو
الدوليه التي تشرف عليها الهيئه اليمنيه
الهيئه العامه للطيران المدني
مساحه 1450 متر مربع تقريبا همم تشمل
مرافق
واماكن الدخول وخروج المسافرين والكبار
الضيوف ليس الجبوا فقط سيصبح متاحا امام
المدنيين في تعز بل حتى البحر والبر ايضا
في ميناء المخاء هذا الذي كان يقتصر العمل
فيه على استقبال الحاويه الصغيره يجري
العمل على ترميمه بما يتسع للحاويات
المتوسطه والكبيره ليصبح احد اهم المنافذ
البحريه في ادخال البضائع ومواد الاغاثه
الى المدنيه
من
خمسه متر لحاله الى 9 متر يعني تسهيل
الحركه من مدينه تعز والمحافظات المجاوره
الى مدينه المخاء تمشق وتعبيد طريق الكدحه
الذي يربط المدينه بالمخاء وبتكلفه تصل
الى ثمانيه ملايين دولار مشروع سيخفف
كثيرا من معاناه المدنيين وسيقرب المسافه
امامهم الى ساعتين على الاكثر للوصول الى
الساحل الغربي سعيد الحدث تعز